hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga my name is liam and you're not
my shoulders are really starting to hurt
mostly due to this channel having to
bear the burden of carrying hunthunt
content on its back whilst we wait for
togashi's hopeful return to form but
today we're going to be optimistic by
looking far far into the future in order
to decipher the ending of the series and
we're going to do that through you yes
you because i asked all of you
association members to tell me how you
think hunt hunter will end so i'm hoping
that this process is like putting
monkeys in a room full of typewriters
and waiting for them to produce
shakespeare and it's all going to begin
with a quick round of netro or netano a
very simple minigame the rules of which
are as follows three proud isaac netaro
stand before you one is our beloved old
man dude whilst the other two are
horrific nen clones and it's going to be
your job to guess which one is the real
netera should you guess incorrectly then
your punishment will be to form an end
vowel by subscribing to the new world
review which will also result in
consistent injections of hunter-based
culture administered directly into your
youtube feed and if you are correct then
netro will give you a high five with the
100 type guanine bodhisattva which
ow so who is the netero and which two
are the netanos make your choice now and
we shall reveal the answer in three two
one and bam it was this guy so if you
guessed incorrectly then you know the
thing to do and please do say hi in the
comments below if you are a new member
of the association welcome but now
onwards with some hunt hunter endings
well for starters i'd like the show to
continue there are so many things i'd
like to see till the end which i think
is a fair enough comment before an
ending i'm sure that we'd all like to
see everything prior to said ending but
with that said that that's not really
quite what i'm after here so we're going
to look elsewhere one last scene with
gone kilauea oreo and karapika i know it
won't happen though yeah i don't think
it'll happen either and for a couple of
reasons actually dealing with all of the
meta stuff first even if we ever were to
reach some sort of dark continent the
idea of hunter hunter making it far
enough to an ending beyond that where we
could see the potential reunion is
i'm gonna call it unlikely but also i
just don't know if karapika is going to
be making it out of this arc in any
state to meet up with anyone by which i
mean he's probably going to be a bit of
a well a bit dead but i would of course
love to see the four of them all
together again i mean when was the last
time that all of they were in the same
room all of they all of them and all of
them were in the same room it's got to
be like all the way back in york new
city because krapika decided not to come
and see gone on the verge of death
during the german election which uh i'm
gonna be honest kind of a dick move
there karapika gone using the lessons he
learned over the course of his journey
to talk nujutsu gyro into not ending
humanity and i like this idea a lot
because it brings hunter hunter full
circle i mean firstly i'm a pretty well
recorded supporter of ghan never being
able to use nen again but that doesn't
necessarily end his future involvement
gon didn't have nen during the hunter
exam so he was forced to talk or even
dare i say think his way out of most
problems solve them creatively rather
than solve them with a big fat or a
punch thing rat so i'd definitely be
keen on seeing non-nen gone having
learnt some lessons from delving too far
into that well and saving the world
through words of wisdom alone heart take
gone going to pito's grave saying i
forgive you which could mean how he
outgrew that hatred and also forgave
himself for what happened to kite
speaking of learning this this would be
a big one although technically speaking
i highly doubt the pitot has a grave but
it would be quite something for gone to
return to the site of the battle and pay
his respects to the creature that he
brutally brutally murdered maybe even
take some responsibility like he did
when kite had to kill the fox bear to
save his life because in the end gone is
supposed to be a character who
understands nature and is highly in tune
with the ways of the animals and pito as
well as all of the chimera and certainly
fall into that category so it would be
really cool for gone to mature mentally
to the point where he has an
understanding of the ants and maybe even
come to view pitot differently sort of
like what happened when knuckle came to
an understanding of yupi that sort of
mental maturity for gone is really one
of the most satisfying avenues of future
growth for him if gone needs to be in
the series at all garappica learning to
let revenge go after crollo becomes the
last one standing ah this this is
interesting actually because at first i
read this and thought er krapika's
already kind of abandoned his business
with the troop but there is a very
golden opportunity here should the rest
of the troop die in some sort of i don't
know hisoka related incident or even
meet their ends via other avenues then
that would put crollo in the exact same
position that the troop put karapika in
crawler would become the last remaining
survivor of his kind and after that
another ball is kind of in kropica's
court does he sympathize with crawler or
does he finish what he started by taking
the head of the spider
or does he do both by putting crowler
out of his misery in order to prevent
him becoming what karapika became and i
know but it's a fun idea especially
considering that togashi estates that
both the true bankrupt because ultimate
fates are to die i honestly think one of
the main reasons why togashi won't
continue the manga is because he is
unsure how to end it when he gets to
that point
maybe i mean i think at least part of
this statement is true the part about
togashi not knowing how to end hunt
hunter is and that's probably the true
bit he just doesn't look anywhere near
that far into the future hunter hunter
almost feels like a more organic world
that has no beginning and no end we just
got to peer inside it for a couple of
years and see what was going on but i
don't think that lack of knowing and
ending is what bothers tagashi because
he could not end the series just as
easily by continuing the story on and on
into infinity because there's always
going to be some sort of weird new thing
he's interested in personally i think
it's a combination of physical ability
and motivation i find it almost
impossible to do anything anything at
all if i'm unmotivated and if drawing
manga causes you this untold physical
pain and keeping it real if you're
already sitting on a net worth of about
25 million dollar dues then i would say
there's very little motivation to do
anything especially considering
togashi's love-hate relationship with
manga as a whole kilauea still has so
much growth i hope his dad awakens his
mortal men and kilowatt has to maximize
the fundamental assassin abilities also
his non-abilities to get close to his
dad but he will ultimately need gon's
help to take him out i have mixed
feelings on this one on the one hand
kilowatt does feel pretty satisfyingly
wrapped up to me he ended his hunt and
discovered what it is he wanted to do
which was to take care of alaka but
there is definitely a lot of unfinished
business within the zoltik family itself
forgetting about silver for a bit
there's also illimi who is actively
targeting kilauea in order to control
alaka so he does seem primed to become a
potential major antagonist but at some
stage in his life killua is going to
need to come to terms with what he is
and what he comes from and as much as we
shouldn't take foreshadowing in this
particular series with any degree of
seriousness there was that one time
where silva stated that he knew kilauea
would return one day so it would tie
everything up quite neatly which is very
much why i don't think it will happen
hunter hunter is very rarely a neat kind
of story things happen those things have
consequences and then we we move on with
our lives without any sort of narrative
resolution i remember hearing i was
supposed to be i i think that means it i
remember hearing it was supposed to be
as long as one piece so if it was that
long i'd love to see gon grow up and see
his powers fully develop if he gets them
back and watch kilauea take over his
family's empire so with the one piece
thing here is a wild statistic one piece
began serialization in july 1997 and
hunt hunt began almost exactly eight
months later in early 1998. however
currently one piece has over 1 000
chapters 1033 at the time of recording
this whilst tanta hunter hasn't even
tipped over that 400 mark and i think
that shows the impact these hiatuses
have had on the series more than
anything else to think that if togashi
had been consistent we'd be looking at
hunter hunter possibly hitting the 1000
chapter mark very soon if not already
which is a pretty insane thought not
that i necessarily think the story would
have gotten that far but at the very
least i imagine it would be well and
truly finished i don't want it to ever
end instead i wanted to continue to
switch from main character to main
character after the previous one
completes here's her goal or dies so
without considering the meta state of
hunter hunter that is entirely possible
weirdly enough hunter hunter has
transitioned from a protagonist-led
shonen into a full-on ensemble cast even
outside of gone kilauea and karapika you
can find a captivating protagonist
absolutely everywhere and the succession
war very much proves that more than
anything we have entire chapters with
just the phantom trooper following the
zodiacs or in fact even the kakin
princes the princes are captivating of
all people or during the palace invasion
where everyone involved served as both a
protagonist and an antagonist emphasis
on the ant in antagonist but i'm always
perfectly happy in hunt hunter to have
characters like moral or knuckle appear
and become lead protagonists for a while
and that's before we even dive into the
potential of existences like jing or
hisoka who could probably command entire
series of their own like the beginning
with everyone running the hunter's exam
now you see that would be a lovely book
and so lovely in fact so that it can
never ever happen i could imagine this
being the case if haunted hunter was a
more standard shonen after the big final
final arc thing we have this great
epilogue where we can see a grown-up
gone step out into a crowd and say my
name is gone freaks and welcome to the
first stage of the hunter exam because
it would be a great bookend to show how
much progress everyone has made since
they were examinees way back in the
early days not in this series though i
just i can't see that happening with
what hunter hunter became although point
of interest here gone is still
technically a hunter right hunters can't
ever have their licenses revoked so even
without being able to use nan he's still
a member of the association so maybe
there is hope for an ending like this
yet jing finding don and learning about
all the secrets of the dark continent
perhaps even deciding to stay there or
returning gloriously so i like this but
i'd even take it one step further like
saying perhaps jing meets don on a fully
grown world tree mirroring the scene
where gone met jing in the human realm
and then don tells jing about the even
darker continent that lies beyond his
grasp and about a book he found written
by the ancient john freaks just clarify
that's a bit of a joke but there is some
great potential for all of hunter hunter
to be this endless cycle of freaks
family members discovering one another
as well as their place in this world all
i know is that the freaks family is
stupidly important more so than many of
the characters of hunter hunter seem to
realize if any actually so it would be
great to delve into their history a bit
more and i guess i'll just throw that on
to the ever-growing pile of things that
togashi probably doesn't care about in
the slightest gone being able to
perfectly control his opi transformation
and use it to beat his father who left
him also meruem and netaro stays alive
after their fight and become friends
that second one's very left field but
about gone if we ever did go in the
direction of him learning how to use nen
again the question of the transformation
would come up because it's entirely
possible that it's a whole new ability
he developed similar to that of biscuit
except the cost of developing this hatsu
was essentially gone's life however
having circumvented that through the
godly being that is nanika that could
leave gone in a situation where he has
more casual access to the adult
transformation if and when he regains
our control i really hope not though i
would like to see my favorite characters
alive and happy particularly the main
four gone killer kropika and leoria you
know thinking about it the only
challenge here is karapika layario can
easily have a happy ending he actually
has a pretty sweet life throughout the
series killua he already kind of has his
happy ending already and gone is a
cheerful young lad again so the only one
really tracking this team down is
karapika who seems absolutely intent on
throwing himself into as much misery as
possible for the sake of collecting a
series of eyeballs how would i like it
to end i'd say yes fair enough as is
this next video because there's always
more to learn exploring experience with
this wonderful series so i look forward
to seeing you there